there were nearly 400 overdose deaths in
Clark County in 2021. that's according
to the Department of Health and Human
Services today community members took
part in the seventh annual Second Chance
5K raising awareness about opioid
addiction Joshua peguero spoke to those
taking part in today's race
along the start line with shorted
running shoes Holly Weaver reflects on
how this race helps her heal my baby
sister Christy overdosed on heroin in
2016. she was only 28 years old when it
happened I realized if it happened in my
family this could happen anywhere
foreign
she co-founded Second Chance 5K its
mission to give people another chance to
find the cure for addiction and I felt
like it was important for people who
struggle with addiction to First feel
like they're real people because they
are and for other people to recognize it
there's been so much shame attached to
this disease along the route of the
second chance 5K are photos of victims
of addiction and they serve as the
reason and purpose for why this walk is
being held while folks were given the
option to walk or run at the 5K located
near Gibbons Elementary some
participants say they just came to honor
victims this is about people who are
suffering families who have suffered
people who know people who are going
through it so we've got to be a part of
something bigger than yourself there
were non-profits at the event with boobs
sharing information on how people can
recover really meeting them where
they're at helping them figure out what
are they willing to do right now to help
them move out of the situation they're
in all the funds raised at the 5K will
go to organizations like no hero and
heroin Vegas stronger and Mission High
School the first school in the country
designed first students recovering from
substance abuse near Alta and Charleston
Joshua figuero eight news now
most of the overdose deaths in Clark
County in 2021 were linked to fentanyl
according to the Southern Nevada Health
District